we have some really great deep dive
long-form videos coming up for you over
the next couple of weeks on the david
pakman show YouTube channel and we've
been working on these mostly because of
the great work that we've been doing
internally with our production staff
with our intern Brian who is here today
everybody is working in concert many of
these topics have been proposed by
people in the audience so during our
upcoming David Pakman show summer
vacation we will be releasing a deep
dive long-form video on classical
liberalism classical liberalism has
become very very trendy and I am going
to make the case to you that classical
liberalism is very effing conservative
and I don't know that everybody
understands that so that is going to be
a great piece coming up we will be doing
a piece on the truth about voter fraud
which the write claims exist exists but
it's not really an issue and voter
suppression which the Left claims exists
and by and large is really an issue that
is going to be a really really great
piece we will be talking about in
another long-form piece the myth of the
violent left you see right wing media
increasingly talking about how violent
the left is when they don't like what's
going on politically it is by and large
a myth and we will also be debunking the
false notion that socialism has never
worked now I know Pat that when we do
this video socialism has never worked be
bummed I'll get called a communist I
don't need to be a communist or
socialist to recognize that it's not
true that socialism has never worked and
if we're going to have a conversation
about economic systems we should at
least be starting with an understanding
of what these economic systems really
are and whether or not they have been
tried and whether they have worked if we
can't even do that what's the point of
talking about capitalism socialism
democratic socialism Marxism whatever so
we are going to be debunking the false
notion that socialism has never worked
and you know what's crazy
I'm not even a socialist and I'm going
to be debunking that don't have a dog in
the fight I don't have a dog and well I
guess arguably I do in the sense that I
am I am for social democracy and the
context of well regulated capitalism but
then I guess no one can talk about
economic models unless they subscribe to
those series of police right this is
it's logically fallacious it's when
sometimes the anti-gay right will say
listen gay people should really not be
involved in the debate about LGBT rights
because they're biased by virtue of
being gay by that same logic shouldn't
straight people not be involved in
discussions about LGBT rights because
they're biased because they're straight
and they also could not actually see how
the issue of LGBT rights affects LGBT
people it doesn't it's David like
reverse identity politics in a way David
you can't talk about Israel because
you're Jewish so your view is biased
isn't someone who's not Jewish also
going to be biased by virtue of not
being Jewish membership in an identity
group does not convey does not signify
bias definitively any more or less than
lack of a membership in that group
anyway we're sort of off on a tangent
but we're going to be be debunking the
idea that socialism has never worked in
and later in the fall after the vacation
we will be doing a long-form piece about
race and IQ we've got a miniseries about
critical thinking and epistemology
planned a lot of really good stuff so
it's going to be a good couple of weeks
on the David Pakman show Channel